[Music]
all right yeah so I'm Alexander I'm
partner and principal consultant for AI
in data science for industry clients so
uh apart from being proactive in a
powerful community I'm also uh yeah
eventually I work as well so and I'd
like to talk and trade so this is the
company good next week we'll be doing so
we consult and enable fines for data
science project and just a few teasers
because we don't have so much time your
Python calls your patent basel urusai pi
pi li the frankfurt with all you acres
they'll and sylvain if you're in the
area and of course this blood you will
see more about this tomorrow so i don't
want to waste too much time on it here
uh so okay
when did the original idea for this talk
start actually it started at PI data
London and 2017 when June Cogan was
giving Aquino who was there may be okay
so cool so he was giving a great keynote
he was called Picasso's terminal and he
was he's an artist and I thought okay
this is like super interesting of course
I'm always like drawn to creative things
because a few of you know my first
career was actually in the music
industry to 90s for techno on house
labels so yeah so um so I thought okay
let's try this let's try okay cool okay
yeah so let's so I you know star
transfer nobodies yes okay yes okay
start on sir the basic idea is you take
a van Gogh picture apply to painting you
apply to a picture and you have the
painting and then go style so this is
the idea of thinking said okay let's try
this all right as a kid I like these
French comics ah it's it's actually
French comics the flock and all and no
it's one of the yarn logo now in French
I don't know what's the Dutch title in
Germany it's alanya of unique so do you
have these then there was also a film
two years ago so far okay let's try this
on a modern DC comic like the flash
which I think now folks but my cup of
tea from the south
I just tried style transfer this is my
very first I transfer actually okay
there's an operation no don't stop
okay so take this part of the picture
here this does not belong to the
presentation so we take a part of this
picture learn style apply it to this
other picture of flash and Kid Flash and
Wow
okay can we get little bit okay
somewhere no power input no no it's not
a touchscreen okay okay so I just
continue talking yeah maybe we just turn
it off and on again so what I just
continue talking a bit so okay so you
can imagine I'd oh you can imagine I was
like super flash
oh here yes yeah take some time yeah
okay so you can imagine this doing this
for the very first time I thought okay
deep learning will solve everything I
mean this is just like amazing I mean it
was just like yeah without it yourself
so I did stuff like that I took a
picture so this is just like a picture
this is the picture this is an excerpt
and I just learned some styles here you
see like this is like okay and I said
Wow oh cool and you know like you can
really play around like also like
rearranging the comics here like just
not taking one page with legging more
like a collage they're just like playing
around so this is what I also talked
about other presentations on this works
always and you can put another comic
here thing or a movie is comic the same
health for star transfer but I also like
to point out because if you read not
post and everything you ever see is
always like these great deep learning
use cases and I'd like to point out no
it's not always working for example if
you see a picture here with a lot of
backlight you see the the Sun actually
is always like a hole so it's not really
being picked up it's not understood and
I'm like my fetus is there are no
backlight picture so the styles are
trained against the Co cool pictures and
I think nobody puts backlight pictures
in a data set so also some old files
maybe but maybe another reason but okay
so the journey also I got this visions
like hey let's do this
what about super excited I had a lot of
fun so I felt like this like hey let's
do this and I thought about what about
this oh so who knows this one - okay
three Germans in the room
okay this is called either by
prioritizing the Three Investigators
it's a very it's like an American
juvenile detective detective stories and
they started in the 1960s for in the
u.s. it's but there's only one spot in
the world where it's popular is Germany
it's going there for since the 70s so I
really grew up with the the cassettes or
as books and there's fresh pilla like
tape rag radio dramas and it's it's like
they they say like I forget stories like
70% of the Hirshman market in Germany so
I thought okay this might be suitable
craft there's a lot of contents so let's
try this for learning marin and also
like to see whether the data is
sufficient and also like try to push to
look into the different aspects as a fun
project to learn from this to apply
maybe to other business use cases to
have a better understanding of this so
it's not really about recreating this
product maybe so okay so if you don't
know Hirschfeld it's the best
translation I could come up with this
tape radio dramas actually it space goes
back to the 1920s um it's like
pre-internet free television so people
who are listening at the radio and they
were like if you have like these movies
without the pictures and you probably
heard about War of the Worlds
so awesome girls the young genius Orson
Welles was also and in there and he put
the first fake documentary basis or a
report there as a radio drama so people
just like do a radio drama sorry and he
was the radio drama was made like all
the Americas is invaded by aliens and
people believed it because this was a
very new format so does the tape so this
has established and stayed in Germany
for quite some time so this is how it
sounds like here Khalil is ever you've
got this many provinces or Nero d'Avola
clownish Pinner
can I write thousand Java at the Mumia I
say whispering mommy so of course what
do we which ingredients do we actually
need to recreate this so we need a story
and a pot we need dialogues we need a
cover picture and we need spoken work
because it's spoken work so and so we
are so what and today I'm going to talk
about the speech partner so so which
resources how we're quiet as in deep
learning like cost time money which
other problems look for which other
problems could we solve for example it's
tie transfer I just found coincidentally
sigh transfer can also be applied to
like a noisy document and to recreate it
in a way very readable again for example
so and now I settle for always like for
this for the same process here so the
first step is almost like the data
acquisition data cleansing research of
paper in the network make it work prove
it's actually working and and then adapt
the solution to the use case and
maximize the quality and always like
changing one a variable at a time
because this is the best way because
this is my but my best advice is only
change one variable at a time because if
you change to and it's not we're no
longer working you just have more work
so the story so far if you're interested
in learning more about the other expects
this some videos from high data will
then last year Europe - and pipe areas
and Florence not some up yet also and to
get to see the other expects so what I
usually do before we start with the
thing is something to put a local thing
here so I last week I was in Florence
the averages movie just hats have been
released so I created this picture with
fashions fur with the Piazza della
Signoria
from Marina Oh Senor Mac never remember
okay and of course I want to do this the
same for here so if you don't know if
you go to Google Maps you can also
explode it they can Al's here and if you
look back you will always see the Google
Maps team having like a joyride it so
for all the canals so I'm here so now
here here we are this is no book
oh yeah and you can reply style here but
you can also for example start doing a
collage here psych so if I take this
picture
I'd put Vincent's to puzzles and
spider-man and I just use my built-in
preview program here in the Mac and
copy/paste everything together no
photoshopping involved put some bubbles
here so here you see this and you can
the star transfer you easily can create
like a comic style of this yeah so or
take another thing so this was like my
local contribute now let's go to the
audio part so the task is actually to
fabricate spoken language and the second
part would be like make it sound like a
known character and of course create
sounds and noises and we're going to
focus on the first part um natural
text-to-speech where there's like
multiple approaches so one approach was
like to concatenate sounds and apply
them this is like maybe built-in
computers
there's wavenet around as different
approaches and at first I want to give
you a little bit an introduction on the
sound space here also there's where they
forms this is like I think the most
common representation of audio here I'm
see this waveform
welcome to PI data Amsterdam 2018 did
you have coffee did you enjoy the view
great yeah you basically see where's
pause noise and I took this from the
video but for example if you take just
like a single sound or a single
frequency it looks like this so this is
the yellow frequency like there's
nothing going on and to get a little
further um if there's a thing called
spectrograms or to spectrogram x-ray
spectrogram of our wave or single
frequency looks like this you only see
like one line here so it's not super
exciting but for example the fee again
listen to Vincent welcome to PI data
Amsterdam 2018 did you have coffee yeah
see did you enjoy the view there's a
pattern here very I hope you can see
from the back because it
a little very light here so you see
that's like different patterns going up
and how actually our so spectrograms I
think are easy to understand without
knowing too much about it you see okay
there's noises and work is what I want
to explain a little bit crash course how
they actually are created so a
spectrogram we take a window from here
from our sound basically apply a fast
Fourier transform here basically then we
look at the frequencies here and the
energy so we see in these frequency
bands we see more it's more less more or
less louder and basically represented by
different colors so if something is like
very loud has a lot of energy it's like
black and if it's like less than one
it's a lighter color and this is
basically how this program is made and
to be read so if you compared like these
two spectrograms one Vincent speaking
the other one frequency it looks like
this
and if you look here inspector grams you
can also see for example is like
different words by Holly ball Barbeau
and by and you see they're a very
similar but there's some differences and
so spectrograms are a very good
representation representation on
basically representing the overtones
because I'm not speaking at just one
frequency when I speak to you there's a
multiple frequencies involved and we can
visualize them with spectrographs so we
see patterns in the structure grams and
if we Kasich we get an idea what's going
on there so yeah and there's also male
spectrograms
arm which we're actually using in the
network in a bit so this is where I'm
heading so Mel spectrogram of a single
frequency looks like this and basically
at first look they look very similar so
what's a male spectrogram actually a
male spectrogram the idea is our ear
filters some frequencies already and the
mouse back to ram is basically doing the
same sort of spectrograms basically just
okay we have input data and we've
represented in the spectrogram and
though the mel spectrogram we basically
it's like signal
of the year maybe so something like that
so we apply different filters on the
like frequency path so we filter more in
the lower levels and filter less in the
higher tone so and this is about
basically our yeah what the similar
thing the ear does already as well for
us so um yeah is that like the overtones
now and I guess you know this welcome to
pie later Amsterdam 2018 did you have
coffee did you enjoy the view
great so basically here you see like
this is like great I mean it's just
great this looks not like this and or if
you look at the spectrogram with many a
lot of noises for example here you have
a lot of noise around but if you must
click the spectrogram you can see like
there's bird calls on a certain
frequency and little certain set so you
can use this for to identify audio and
there's also like are just like effects
when they put like hidden messages into
so this is its formula or from FX win so
they from the music title says the
spectrogram and they hide a picture in
there like you can even have kept
pictures in the spectrogram well crazy
do this immediately well the best talk
ever learned how to cap pictures into
music yeah
ok souls what's tackled run to then so
actually the first if you've heard as
that first heard about Chaco Tron said
ok this is a really crazy idea we have
like a network but the thing is it
learned on the male spectrograms which
is like ok do we actually learn from
pictures we didn't order I'll say a bit
later so the thing is you just put um
text and the audio into this network to
have the network learn how to speak yeah
so say ok you can put some text in there
and get like a voice out of it here's
this ability this is the taco Tron
original not to to to give you a little
bit more impression so what is it so
actually like the basic ideas you have
here in the tacho Tron original we have
like a linear scale spectrogram
and the ideas basically we get on all
the characters in and we have an RNN and
basically we just aligned the characters
through the picture that's the basic the
very basic idea where oversimplified
idea of this network and there's also
like if you want to have a closer look
here it's yeah that's a little bit more
on this so and the changes there with
May will target run to here is to use
LST apps also like more convolutions and
to use the mouse back to graphs here so
and basically the most important part to
get here is so actually the convolution
is deciding on which parts to focus on
the Mel spectrogram and to align it to
the characters because still just
putting some text and audio material
into a network and to produce results
like my intuition this can never work
this is like too crazy so okay so um
here so again a little bit closer so if
I put like text here to to the children
mouth welcome to play games to them 2018
did you have coffee superlative you it's
not like text letter to spectrum
dispossess there's like all your hands
and basically only a Winston but we know
there's some audio interaction going on
so it's not like we can not linearly
basically combine letter to speech it so
that's why I think it's quite
interesting concept okay now a little
bit about PI torch which I use to
implement or like for for draining the
great things with PI torch are for me
it's my torch uses conventional
programming practices so height works
basically very object orientated that's
I think that's why it makes it so easy
to use the faery program you can read
part it's really easy to debug simple
and transparent and it's also like
simple to debug because you can even go
or use like an IDE like PyCharm to eat
the debugger and really see what are the
outcomes in
and while you train the network and to
stop and see maybe what's going wrong
maybe if their dimensions don't do not
fit and something like that and the
other thing is arm it's super simple to
write code which can run on the CPU
maybe for prototyping or just like to
get the first steps but also to move the
home the thing to the CPU and also like
tight arch although it feels like very
new the torch project is pretty awesome
it just was Lua and now it's available
for us so how does pi touch look like
this is a like a custom Ella lsdm
example here you so you see we just
create a class and have an init function
here the folder if we define how we want
to have the forward function and that's
it and basically here we have a building
lsdm we can just put in some parameters
and we don't really have to code a lot
to create like complex networks like
this because remember like if I want you
to put the code for example for tackle
tool here I meet maybe like five six
seven pages because you see it's like
very complex network but still it's very
simple to build with pi torch for
example this is how I can define my
encoder decoder I just say okay this is
decoder this is a class I take off the
shelf or I've maybe modified this to my
needs and I just pass in some parameters
and I use one of the optimizes for
example here I just use the madam and
cross-entropy off as a criterion and
it's all built in so basically it's just
really like plug and play and if you are
good in Python programming or if you
have a decent knowledge is very it's
actually very simple as I could dream
come true so and this is like how the
training looks like for example so it's
just like to find a training function
for example here is an example so if
CUDA so somewhere else here there's a
variable set if GPU is available I move
stuff to keep you and otherwise it just
stays on the CPU and of course usually I
like to use my CPU yeah yeah
it's very easy to get started in flight
watch I think the best resource is
actually the PI Taj Project website
there are great tutorials there's a
great and very responsive community
there are the documentation is well
written it's constantly updated and yeah
it's it's really easy to get started so
if you for example interested hey I'll
be like the star transfer that's a great
prop post you can get you going with
reference for there but you should know
up front this um and I think there's
very often a big gap because usually I
use I rant a lot about deep learning and
Jupiter notebooks because this is the
worst code you see online as deep
learning
Jupiter notebooks yeah because there's a
lot it works in a notebook but it's not
productive you cannot really move the
code you kind of reuse it it's basically
just in the space of this one notebook
it's fine but it's sometimes even how to
read if you have variables used in a
function somewhere at the end of the
notebook and they're defined up foreign
so there's no real programmatic
structure in these notebooks you very
often see online and so I think you need
to get a better grasp on how -
object-oriented programming works and
how to structure a I would say a larger
like not a super big one but not a
trivial a set of modules and how to
interact with them because usually the
best part is to interact with the shell
and put some parameters here alright so
um this is how I started to work so I
was so there's like these GPUs you can
use now Thunder pool free you have like
high speed you can have like it's
external graphic card so this is was
this was the basic idea though but the
thing is it's not plug-and-play
especially uh I would not recommend it
if you have a Mac because the video
drivers are currently not updated so I'm
stuck with an old operating system here
which is really bad um so I my
recommendation is if you want to use a
cheese if you don't have like a Lampasas
just usually get a Linux box not a Mac
don't fire Mac for this get Linux books
you can put one or multiple GPUs in
there you can also of course rent all
this in the cloud or what I have for
longer long-running
project thank you for longer running
projects I have there's a server at
half-smile it cost like a hundred bucks
so a month and then I can have something
running with one GJ x 1080 oh there okay
then yes so you remember this um since I
rented a little ball coding I have to
give also like a good credit to the
Nvidia some Nvidia engineers and because
they created a really nice piece of
software and put it online for this
network so I can really recommend go
there look what they did how they
arranged it it's a beautiful piece so it
was really easy to use and basically
yeah I was I was very building and on
the shoulders of giants as we saw here
so ok damn for speech synthesis I was
lucky to find an English dataset with 24
hours of audio recorded by one person
and put it into the network or it has
clips from 1 to 10 seconds so you always
have like a clip or file and what the
text is being spoken
it's like 24 hours of text and it's in a
public domain and it's also like San
Andreas so yeah so training the network
we put audio snippets and the texts for
these audio snippets in a network and
that's let's do this so the network is
always reading this text here like after
10 hours it sounds like this
everything's fine with us after 14 hours
it's a pond and it is in other than
leaving me sorry
although the more you the facts happened
here
I had call it yeah he woke up and after
9 days once upon a time there was a
little mermaid named siren who lived
with her stepmother under the sea she
get to go out to sea like any other I
mean this is not a replacement for lexer
but given the resources I need it for
this with the right data Wow
and so I was I was quitting so actually
to recreate it could also do something
like this
welcome to my data Amsterdam 2019 did
you have coffee raped but actually pie
data is that pie data's was not I mean
it was quite amazing what you picked up
so of course let's do this in German so
what I requires audio snippets and in
German and I was looking and there was
no data set available so I said okay
let's do this or we can do this there's
audio snippets they can use audio books
newspapers and the requirements is just
like I need humans to prefer the data
set so I reached out to my business
partners in sincere oh my three people I
need some people like doing these audio
clips and see you said Alex I really
love your talks but oh okay so I had to
come but sometimes it's good limited
resources remember this limited
resources are good Chicago House came
out of nothing
jungle music came out of an economic
crisis in the UK at the time the whole
thing so limited resources a good
because they make you think so and so I
tried okay how case there way I can see
me automate it so it was actually I
found a newspaper the newspaper the good
thing is they just with a limited set of
speakers they read the newspaper without
audio clips without music with all all
this so I use the transcription service
to get the word next to see me
automatically create all your sentence
okay I have to speed up maybe I need a
little more time okay yes so yeah okay
so the transcription so my assumption
was like this transcription is really
good so I'm speeding up here a bit
transcription is really good because we
hear all about these like our great
conference great announcement but it's
all for English because actually for
German there was only Google available
and with a I and I used the Google
service and it was not available on the
other services what I accept
it also expected a good quality it's
just like it's recorded audio for
professional speakers so I really I
think the description was soft but
actually the quality wasn't really good
so I got this data set also I have
subscription so I scraped the audio and
yeah and I just have clean reading so I
even like the newspaper gave me some API
access but it was not really helpful
because it was basically only the titles
and when it was released so it was not
not so much to do so I scraped it with
selenium and I can really recommend
selenium here not using scrape here
beautiful selenium you see directly what
you do in a browser so it's really fast
to scrape a specific website if you
don't have to scale okay um so I put the
data and in two-way rough and there's a
nice library called audio talk which I
can use for audio tokenizing and I used
then these snippets I put in to to the
Google cloud to get them that
transcribed to get the time index oh I
also tried some Python libraries and
other things and the transcription
quality was beyond being worth to
mention it was really bad so and of
course and of course the text was
cleanup numbers and their abbreviations
will put into real language so and a
buildin all module to glue everything
together again so with all your talk I
think this is really easy to get with
all your talk you can say ok and if the
energy if there's a pauses you can just
like give some parameters and audio talk
will create snippets from audio because
it's a really cool libraries very nice
to interact you you see for example this
is all I have to put in if I say ok like
I have like energy 55 like energy is
like how long something is and maximum
12 second snippets I can create a loop
symbol line like this ok so if I feed
this to the Google transcription service
you get a JSON you see you Jason you see
a word and the timing index and this is
a low really low quality so this is just
like this is not like I didn't really
have search for something specific so
this was like the average here
you see every all the words in red are
false or wrong so we have extra words we
have wrong words words missing I was
what was I was expecting like better
quality actually so don't run don't
scream yeah we can skip that so okay so
um I adapted the same format for LJ
speech to make it simple so I just just
cook clock it talk and play into my
transcripts so okay so um I have all
this and let's let's try this um
no Trent of kind talent for God knows or
has the scheme of EDA original recording
so actually I made in the network a
little bit simpler by feeding the text
it actually you train so this was a
little trick of the trade here just like
to get a little better person after 48
hours it sounded like this also sounds
like scary humans like ghosts and stuff
but yeah but after 96 hours if you know
about this little take you have these
two input and output Specter ramps and
if you compare them you see usually if
you if you expect a straight line here
if they align well you see they don't
really align well so no surprise what
had happened what has happened actually
so actually my speaker theorization
didn't work well so I had too many
speakers in the data set and actually
especially I have some female voices in
there so when female voices are at a
higher pitch so there's a big gap like
dark for speaking men because you read a
series newspaper or check article and
and other features are in female
speakers so actually I removed I just
said okay let's settle I try to find one
to focus on one male speaker as good as
I could
there's some different libraries for
that I don't didn't really have a strong
preference here so you can alter them
then we can come up with something like
this no it's not of kind to names
being disorderly our Blackmun's will
truly be under Putin bosomed us back
sorry
okay so you know the German texts
already after 24 hours don't frankly
think I intend that it's nice to see mr.
busy Student Activities after five days
though jumped up nine times for Gordon
Vargas this is my mini namu wrote about
me and selfish ruining the young people
trade for the kizomba Musante mMmmm but
after ten days doctrine Thoth can turn
for God
nice to see mojito also ensuring the
unreported Philebus under stalin - yeah
so given it was just like automatic
there's there's still a lot of
optimization potential Union in the the
ground in the data used for this I think
this was also like not too bad for the
resources thrown in it so so this is I
think this is why we should look at
people learning in a different way maybe
I see deep learning is more like it's
like raw it's like it's like iron and
you you Forge it like a blacksmith and
you can get it like a tool in a certain
direction and maybe like 95 profit
percent are just like for it is a good
tool so and I think I was pretty
impressed and I'm trying to remember
this maybe there's some totally
different use cases them for speech
because I don't really want to get it to
the competition with Siri or laxer or
whatever yeah so um first explanation
here is throw more data in the space
because there's audio books and off the
same speakers to see okay well the
network and prove and even pick up more
the characteristics because what's also
quite obvious the the speaker
characteristics are picked up as well
it's very sensitive to if - hey trineas
data set um so networks the learning
lesson here networks they don't
generalize well very often so some some
just some noisy data can basically make
the network collapse
and also look into new tech which is
coming out in a space which is like
everyday so if you want to get a better
understanding of the whole thing if you
don't know they still pop go there and
just great explanation for many things
in there a high space if you want to
look in the audio there's a great music
retriever will come with many techniques
and audio processing and - with jupiter
notebooks examples this great place and
if you want to play around with
cutting-edge and natural language
naturally through networks there's also
great site with papers with code which I
can recommend to get you started to just
like try and I really want to this is my
advice I'd go there play with AI on it's
not probably the best solution yet for
solving business and real-life problems
but I think it's a really great space to
explore and I'm sure they will be some
where you go to use cases in the future
solving problems thank you
[Applause]